here's what would happen if you fell
into Jupiter
due to Jupiter's strong gravity you'd be
falling from the top of the atmosphere
at nearly 180 000 kilometers per hour
after about 250 kilometers of falling
you'd reach Jupiter's ammonia clouds
these have minus 150 degrees Celsius
temperatures as well as incredibly
powerful winds about 12 hours into your
fall the temperature would start rising
in so would the atmospheric pressure as
you reach the inner layers of Jupiter
there'd be parts that you'd be able to
swim through if you could handle it the
temperature would be as hot as the
surface of the Sun and if that's not
enough you'd also be experiencing
atmospheric pressure equal to 2 million
times the pressure you feel on earth
eventually you'd reach Jupiter's core
and you'd be stuck there because of all
that atmospheric pressure so